Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It's all true, or it ought to be. So said Winston Churchill of the legend of King Arthur. Romantic historical story or just an invented myth? Well, welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Samaruk, and my very own Mordred, Tom Holland. Tom.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这一切都是真的，或者说它本该如此。温斯顿·丘吉尔在评价亚瑟王传奇时曾这样说道。这是一段浪漫的历史故事，还是一个凭空捏造的神话？欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·萨马鲁克，还有我专属的莫德雷德，汤姆·霍兰德。汤姆。
I should tell you that in the script, Dominic, it says my very own Galordred, Tom Holland. Tom. I should say that in the script, in the script, Dominic, it says my very own Galahad. I know, but I was never going to read that out. I was never going to read that out. Very subtly done. Yeah. I was hoping you wouldn't notice. So let's kick off. This is a great subject. King Arthur was my very first historical enthusiasm. So I read the Lady Bird King Arthur books. I read Antonia Fraser's book about the Knights of the historical enthusiasm. So I read the Lady Bird King Arthur books. I read Antonia Fraser's book about the Knights of the Round Table. And I think I read those before I read anything about real kings. That was probably true of lots of people who get into history, isn't it?
我得告诉你，剧本里写的是，我专属加洛德雷德，汤姆·霍兰德。汤姆。我应该说，剧本里，多米尼克，剧本里写的是我专属的加拉哈德。我知道，但我根本没打算念出来。我根本没打算念出来。做得非常微妙。是的。我本来希望你没注意到。那我们开始吧。这是一个极好的话题。亚瑟王是我最初的历史热情所在。我读过瓢虫版（Ladybird）的亚瑟王书籍。我还读过安东尼娅·弗雷泽（Antonia Fraser）关于圆桌骑士的书。我想我在读任何关于真正的国王的东西之前，就已经读过这些了。对许多对历史感兴趣的人来说，这可能都是真的，对吧？
You start with King Arthur and Robin Hood, and then you get into the, you know, enclosures and dissolution of the monasteries and all the really exciting, glamorous subjects. Yes. There's always the vague feeling, attaching to reading about the enclosures that nights nights with penance are just a lot more fun um and i suppose hanging over this entire theme is the obvious one uh which summed up very effectively by Tom McTague, the UK correspondent for The Atlantic, who asks, Arthur, who, what, why, how?
你从亚瑟王和罗宾汉开始，然后你进入了，你知道的，圈地运动、解散修道院以及所有那些真正令人兴奋、光彩夺目的主题。是的。读到圈地运动时，总有一种模糊的感觉，觉得苦修骑士要有趣得多，嗯，而且我想，笼罩在这个整个主题之上的，是一个显而易见的问题，嗯，《大西洋月刊》英国通讯员汤姆·麦克泰格（Tom McTague）对此进行了非常精辟的总结，他问道：亚瑟，是谁，什么，为什么，如何？
I guess you could express that as basically, did he exist? Yeah. So Dominic, are you a sceptic or a believer? Well, that's it. To my mind, I guess if I like to believe that arthur existed of course because i'm a romantic but ultimately i suppose my my instinct is that there were multiple arthur's right that probably there were multiple warlords and generals some of them roman leftovers some of them celtic some of them maybe even germanic um who sort of fed into the Arthur legend at the end of Roman Britain
我想你可以把它表达为，基本上，他存在过吗？是的。那么，多米尼克，你是个怀疑论者还是信徒？好吧，就是这样。在我看来，我想我愿意相信亚瑟存在过，当然，因为我是个浪漫主义者，但最终我想我的直觉是，存在着多个亚瑟，对吧？可能存在着多位军阀和将军，其中一些是罗马遗留势力，一些是凯尔特人，有些甚至可能是日耳曼人，嗯，他们在大罗马不列颠时期结束时，某种程度上汇入了亚瑟的传奇之中。
in that sort of period that we think of as the Dark Ages. And that, you know, it wasn't completely invented that there must have been grains of truth, as there always are in historical myths. But anyway, Tom, this is your field, you're on home turf. You should be answering this question. I don't think he existed. You know, this word, euorrhagism um the idea that yes that um in the distant past you have mortals kings powerful figures who go on over the course of time become elevated and end up as gods yeah but i think that arthur is a kind of interesting example
在我们认为黑暗时代的那个时期。而且，你知道，这并不是完全凭空捏造的，其中一定有真相的内核，正如历史神话中一贯的那样。但无论如何，汤姆，这是你的领域，你在你的主场。你应该来回答这个问题。我认为他不存在。你知道，这个词，欧赫麦罗主义（euhemerism），嗯，这种观点认为，是的，在遥远的过去，你有凡人、国王、有权势的人物，随着时间的推移，他们变得崇高起来，最终成了神，是的，但我认为亚瑟是一个相当有趣的例子，
of uh something going the opposite way that i think he's essentially a kind of mythical figure, a figure of folklore, who gets attached to a specific historical narrative. And the reason that that can work is that, as you said, the setting for Arthur are the century, maybe two centuries after the collapse of Roman Britain, which is the two century period, that really we struggle to fit a narrative onto it. We have so few written sources and the evidence from archaeology, from genetics, everything is so contradictory and so complex that in a sense, if you wanted to slot a mythical figure and pretend, imagine, cast him, construct him as someone who had actually existed, that's the period that you would do it but i think that um i guess there are two problems really one is that the the sources that mention
关于嗯，某种走向相反方向的事物，我认为他本质上是一个神话人物，一个民间传说中的人物，被附加到了一个特定的历史叙事上。之所以能行得通，是因为正如你所说，亚瑟的背景是罗马不列颠崩溃后的一个世纪，也许是两个世纪，这是一个历时两个世纪的时期，我们真的很难将一个叙事套用到它上面。我们拥有的文字记录如此之少，来自考古学、遗传学的证据，一切都如此矛盾、如此复杂，以至于在某种程度上，如果你想插入一个神话人物，并假装、想象、把他塑造、构造为一个真正存在过的人，那就是你会选择的时期，但我认为，嗯，我想实际上有两个问题，一个是提及
arthur are incredibly late right so they're well after the event yes almost so there's there's um there's a description of um a raid that was launched by um some welsh-speaking britons from the region of edinburgh against what's thought to be the roman fort of cataric and this is set about well about 600 and the guy who is describing it claims at the beginning of the poem a guy called anerian, I am narrating it. And he's supposed to have lived around 600. And in that poem, there is a phrase that this warlord pulls off great feats, but he was not Arthur, is the phrase. So if we can identify that at 600, then that is evidence for it being very early.
亚瑟的源头极其滞后，对吧？所以它们远在事件发生之后，是的，几乎是这样，所以，有一个对嗯，一桩由一些来自爱丁堡地区的讲威尔士语的不列颠人发起的袭击的描述，袭击目标被认为是卡塔里克（Catarick）的罗马堡垒，这件事发生在，大约600年左右，而描述它的那个人在诗歌开头声称，一个叫阿内里温（Aneurin）的人，我在讲述它。他本应该生活在600年左右。在那首诗里，有一个短语，说这个军阀完成了伟大的功绩，但“他不是亚瑟”，这就是那个短语。因此，如果我们能将这一点确定在600年，那么这就是它非常早期的证据。
And Arthur being somebody that people will know and that people will say, is he an Arthur, isn't he? So that's pretty big, isn't it? I mean, doesn't that suggest... Except that. Except that. This is a poem that was first written down in the 9th century and the earliest manuscript we have of it is the 13th century. So there's a lot of potential for Chinese whispers there.
而亚瑟是人们会知道、人们会说“他是亚瑟吗，他不是吗”的人。所以这分量很重，不是吗？我的意思是，这难道不表明……除了……除了……这是一首最初写于9世纪的诗，而我们拥有的最早手稿是13世纪的。因此，那里有很大的口耳相传（中国传话）的可能。
And even if it was written in 600, he was no Arthur. I mean, Arthur could still be a mythical figure. Yes, like you'd say he was no Heracles or, yeah. Yes, exactly, exactly. And then what about these people like Gildas? So Gildas is somebody who writes about Arthur, isn't he? Tell me about Gildas. Right, so Gildas is, again, difficult to pin him down exactly, but he's Tell me about Gildas. Right, so Gildas is probably, again, difficult to pin it down
即使它写于600年，他也不是亚瑟。我的意思是，亚瑟仍然可能是一个神话人物。是的，就像你会说他不是赫拉克勒斯或，是的。是的，没错，没错。那么像吉尔达斯（Gildas）这样的人呢？吉尔达斯是一个写到过亚瑟的人，对吧？跟我讲讲吉尔达斯。好吧，吉尔达斯是，同样，很难确切地锁定他，但他告诉我关于吉尔达斯的。好吧，吉尔达斯可能，同样，很难确切地锁定
exactly, but he's probably writing about 500. And he does give a kind of garbled narrative of what's going on, even though it's completely shot through with all kinds of Old Testament imagery. So he's not writing a kind of straight history. And he does give us, he gives us a portrait of a haughty tyrant who subsequently gets identified with a guy called Vortigern, inviting Saxon mercenaries in. Then you have Britain imploding. You have a state of warfare. And this conventionally is the period that you associate with Arthur. But it's not Arthur who is mentioned.
他，但他可能在500年左右写作。他确实提供了一种对当时局势的混乱叙述，尽管其中完全浸透了各种旧约图像。因此他并不是在写一种直截了当的历史。他确实给了我们，他给我们描绘了一个傲慢暴君的肖像，此后来被认定为名叫伏提庚（Vortigern）的人，他邀请了萨克逊雇佣兵。然后你不列颠就陷入了内爆。你有了战争状态。而这通常被认为是与亚瑟相关的时期。但被提及的并不是亚瑟。
It's a guy called Ambrosius Aurelianus, who is described as the last of the Romans. And Arthur isn't there. It's a yawning gap. So why does Gildas not mention Arthur? I guess there are various... But hold on, don't people think that Ambrosius Aurelianus is Arthur? That's a lot of the stuff that I've read. People say, well, this is obviously Arthur. That was his real name. Is that just balderdash? It's kind of quite desperate because he's not called Arthur.
是一个叫安布罗斯·奥雷利安努斯（Ambrosius Aurelianus）的人，他被描述为最后的罗马人。而亚瑟不在那里。这是一个巨大的空白。那么，为什么吉尔达斯没有提到亚瑟呢？我想有各种……但是等等，难道人们不认为安布罗斯·奥雷利安努斯就是亚瑟吗？我读过很多这方面的内容。人们说，好吧，这显然就是亚瑟。那是他的真名。这难道只是胡说八道吗？这多少有点绝望，因为他不叫亚瑟。
I mean, he's called Drogosius Aurelianus. So why is Gildas not mentioning Arthur? It could be because he hasn't heard of him. So Arthur is operating in some other area of the country that the Gildas hasn't heard. Or it could be that Gildas has a problem with Arthur. So in a lot of the early saints' lives that you get in Wales and other Celtic areas, Arthur is often cast as a kind of problematic figure who preys on the church.
我的意思是，他叫德罗戈修斯·奥雷利安努斯（Drogosius Aurelianus）。所以为什么吉尔达斯没有提到亚瑟？可能是因为他没听说过他。所以亚瑟在国家的其他某个区域活动，而吉尔达斯没有听说过。或者可能是吉尔达斯对亚瑟有意见。所以在威尔士和其他凯尔特地区流传的许多早期圣徒传记中，亚瑟经常被塑造成一个掠夺教会的问题人物。
So perhaps that's the reason. So he's been cancelled. Gildas has cancelled him. Yeah, or perhaps he just doesn't exist. You know, he's an imaginary figure. And I think that that's the likeliest explanation. Where Arthur does appear in what seems to be a historical record is in a Welsh series of texts, of chronicles and so on that is attached to the name of um a welsh writer called nennius but again it's all very confusing and this is the one that gives the
所以也许这就是原因。因此他被取消了。吉尔达斯取消了他。是的，或者也许他根本不存在。你知道，他是个虚构的人物。我认为这最有可能的解释。亚瑟确实出现在看似历史记录中的地方，是在一系列威尔士文本、编年史等当中，这些文本署名于一个名叫嗯，名叫涅尼乌斯（Nennius）的威尔士作家，但同样，这一切非常混乱，这就是那个列出
famous list of 12 battles that arthur is supposed to have won culminating in the battle of baden which we can be fairly confident is a battle that was fought because gildas mentions it but he he doesn't associate with arthur he doesn't even specifically say that it's ambrosius aurelianus who won the battle of baden he doesn't say who the battle of baden was against um he doesn't really provide a solid date for it so the whole thing is a kind of it's it's a mess and i think that that being so you've got to ask well why and how would the legend of Arthur emerge? And I think that it's pretty clear that what's going on is that you have a Welsh speaking tradition that is very hostile to what it sees as a takeover of its lands by Saxons. And likewise, in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, you have a very similar account of Saxons and Angles sweeping westwards, conquering the homelands of the Britons, pushing them into
亚瑟据称赢得的12场著名战役的文本，其高潮是巴顿山之役（Battle of Badon），我们可以相当确信这是一场曾经打过的战役，因为吉尔达斯提到了它，但他并没有将它与亚瑟联系起来，他甚至没有明确说是安布罗斯·奥雷利安努斯赢得了巴顿山之役，他没有说巴顿山之役是对抗谁的，他也没有为它提供一个坚实的日期，所以整件事就是一种，它是一团糟。鉴于如此，你不得不问，好吧，亚瑟的传奇为什么以及如何会出现？我认为很明显，发生的情况是，你拥有一个讲威尔士语的传统，它对它所看到的萨克逊人对其土地的接管非常敌视。同样，在《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中，你有一个非常相似的叙述，讲的是萨克逊人和盎格鲁人向西席卷，征服不列颠人的家园，将他们推向
Wales, seen from the other side. And traditionally, this has been understood to be a historical narrative that the Romans withdraw, that the Britons invite in the Saxons, the Saxons then conquer what becomes England. Arthur supposedly wins the Battle of Baden, keeps the Saxons at bay for a few decades, the Saxons then come back in. And that's a kind of narrative that has been repeated and repeated and is still kind of widely held to. But I think it's a fantastical one. That's not what actually the archaeological evidence shows and it's not what the genetic evidence shows let me interrupt you so modern sort of academic historians very recently especially if they're sort of quite sort of um quite woke shall we say they think that this is the wrong narrative because it presents immigration as kind of contested and it's all done with fire and sword and they sort of
威尔士，从另一面看。传统上，这被理解为一个历史叙事：罗马人撤退，不列颠人邀请萨克逊人进入，萨克逊人随后征服了后来的英格兰。亚瑟据称赢得了巴顿山之役，将萨克逊人阻挡了几十年，然后萨克逊人又卷土重来。这是一种被反复重复、至今仍然广为接受的叙事。但我认为这是一个荒诞的故事。这并不是考古证据实际显示的情况，也不是基因证据显示的情况。让我打断你一下，所以现代的一些学术历史学家最近，特别是如果他们是那种相当嗯，相当“觉醒”（woke）的人，他们认为这是一个错误的叙事，因为它把移民表现为一种充满争议的过程，而且一切都是通过血与火完成的，他们会争辩说，
argue oh no it was much more gradual and there was an assimilation that the the idea that the Saxons came in and they drove Arthur and the Britons all into Wales is all balderdash and it was this sort of multicultural process and all the rest of it do you buy all that is that your take on it all I don't think it's about um woke anxieties about immigration i think it's about the fact that um all the evidence on the ground the archaeological evidence shows very little sign and the genetic evidence shows very little sign of a kind of mass invasion basically the the angles and the saxons like the welsh are they're all descended from the people who lived in Roman
哦，不，这个过程要渐进得多，存在着同化，萨克逊人入侵并把亚瑟和不列颠人全赶进威尔士的观点纯属胡说八道，这是一个多元文化的过程，诸如此类。你买账吗？这就是你对这一切的看法吗？我不认为这是关于对移民的“觉醒”焦虑，我认为这是因为，嗯，实地所有的考古证据显示出的迹象微乎其微，基因证据显示的迹象也微乎其微，表明曾发生过大规模入侵。基本上，盎格鲁人和萨克逊人就像威尔士人一样，他们都是生活在罗马不列颠的人的后代。
Britain. What seems to have happened is that, for reasons that we can't be absolutely certain about, that the eastern half of the former province of Britannia starts to identify culturally with the kind of the Germanic reaches of the North Sea. And it's a conscious reaction against Romanitas, against the ideals of Rome. And almost as if in reaction to that, the western half of Britain, which had always been less Romanised, very, very radically starts to identify with Roman history, Roman precedents, and so on. And essentially, by the time you get to the 9th and 10th century what has happened is that um these different stories these different traditions these different back projections have come to be fossilized so that both the welsh and the
似乎发生的情况是，由于我们无法完全确定的原因，不列颠尼亚前行省的东半部开始在文化上认同北海的日耳曼地区。这是对“罗马性”（Romanitas）、对罗马理想的一种有意识的反抗。几乎就像是对这种反抗的回应，不列颠的西半部——原本受罗马化程度就较低——非常、非常激进地开始认同罗马历史、罗马先例等等。本质上，当你到了9世纪和10世纪时，发生的事情是，嗯，这些不同的故事、这些不同的传统、这些不同的事后追溯已经变得僵化了，以至于威尔士人和
anglo-saxons believe that there was a kind of genuine migration but there's that there is you know in terms of of the essentially the kind of the cutting edge of academic research at the moment there's no evidence at all for this migration and so therefore it becomes more difficult to fit arthur into that that narrative well okay let's let's let's get let's let's get back stuck into arthur the idea of there being somebody called Arthur, this incredibly romantic figure, when does that really kick in? At what point are educated people swapping the story of Arthur and embellishing it?
盎格鲁-撒克逊人都相信曾有过一种真正的移民潮，但在目前学术研究的前沿方面，根本没有证据支持这种移民潮，因此，要将亚瑟塞进那个叙事中就变得更加困难了。好吧，让我们，让我们重新回到亚瑟身上，关于存在一个叫亚瑟的人、这个极其浪漫的人物这种想法，它究竟是什么时候真正兴起的？受过教育的人是在哪个时间点开始交流亚瑟的故事并对其进行美化的？
So is this pre-Norman conquest? This becomes widespread? Or is it after that? Well, you're getting it with Nennius, whoever Nennius was, if you know. well you're getting it with nennius whoever nennius was if you know you so you're getting it in um uh as the anglo-saxons are starting to kind of solidify the kingdom of england so you are getting arthur enshrined as a kind of folk hero for the welsh and but not the saxons right they they absolutely not no no no and and so for alfred doesn't i mean
所以这是在诺曼征服之前吗？这变得普遍了吗？还是在那之后？好吧，你从涅尼乌斯那里看到了，不管涅尼乌斯是谁，如果你知道的话。好吧，你从涅尼乌斯那里看到了，不管涅尼乌斯是谁，如果你知道的话，所以你从嗯，随着盎格鲁-撒克逊人开始巩固英格兰王国时看到了它，所以你看到亚瑟被奉为威尔士人的一种民间英雄，但不是萨克逊人，对吧？他们绝对不是，不，不，因此对于阿尔弗雷德来说，难道他
he either doesn't know about arthur or he thinks arthur is a bad guy am i right yeah so arthur is not mentioned by beat who essentially provides the only narrative that we have for what we could call the dark ages uh gets picked up by by alfred who is sponsoring the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle. The Anglo-Saxon Chronicle doesn't mention Arthur either. So essentially, Arthur becomes a folk hero for the Welsh, a reminder of victories won over the Saxons, as they're called. And there's a kind of implicit sense of prophecy. So you also get in Nennius, I think, the first mention of Merlin. With Merlin's prophecies, he is saying that the time will come where the Britons will essentially get back the lowlands, Logra. They will get back England. So it's this idea that Arthur will come again, that the Welsh will reverse the humiliation of their defeat.
要么不知道亚瑟，要么认为亚瑟是个坏家伙，我说的对吗？是的，所以比德（Bede）没有提到亚瑟，比德基本上为我们所称的黑暗时代提供了唯一的叙事，亚瑟被赞助《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》的阿尔弗雷德选中。《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》也没有提到亚瑟。因此，本质上，亚瑟成了威尔士人的民间英雄，是对战胜萨克逊人（如他们所称）的胜利的提醒。并且有一种潜在的预言感。所以我想你在涅尼乌斯那里也能看到对梅林（Merlin）的首次提及。伴随着梅林的预言，他说那个时刻将会到来，不列颠人基本上将夺回低地，洛格里亚（Logres）。他们将夺回英格兰。所以这就是亚瑟将再次归来、威尔士人将逆转他们失败的屈辱的观点。
That's essentially what's powering it. That sort of fantasy because it never happened. Is that what you're saying? That he's basically inventing this humiliation that never actually took place? The Anglo-Saxons, obviously, they identify with the more Germanic traditions to the degree that they end up speaking a Germanic language, that they take on Germanic names, that they take on germanic names that they um trace their origins back to um germanic gods yeah um and so culturally this then becomes dominant over the lowlands and the romanized christian welsh are pushed into as they say into into the mountain fastnesses and that's the great cultural divide um and it's one of obviously
这基本上就是推动它的动力。那种幻想，因为它从未发生过。你是这个意思吗？他基本上是在凭空捏造一场从未真正发生过的屈辱？盎格鲁-撒克逊人，显然，他们认同更多的日耳曼传统，以至于他们最终说日耳曼语，他们采用日耳曼名字，他们采用日耳曼名字，他们将自己的起源追溯到日耳曼神灵，是的，因此在文化上，这随后在低地占据了统治地位，而罗马化的基督教威尔士人则被推入，正如他们所说，推入山地要塞，这就是伟大的文化分界线，显而易见的是，
that um survives the norman conquest and that then muddies the waters further because essentially arthur is an inspiration to the welsh and then also he becomes quite a potent figure for the norman conquerors and and their heirs because again it's kind of putting the english down yeah and really the guy who popularizes arthur as a historical figure is writing in the early 12th century and that's jeffrey of monmouth so this is laura lawson's question laura lawson we should get into some questions now i reckon yes um because you and i can talk about King Arthur for, I mean, maybe people were happy to hear it, but we could probably talk a witter on for days between ourselves.
这种分界线在诺曼征服后得以存续，然后这使水体进一步混浊，因为本质上亚瑟对威尔士人是一种启发，然后他也成为了诺曼征服者及其继承人的一个颇具潜力的强力人物，因为这同样是在贬低英格兰人，是的，而真正将亚瑟普及为历史人物的人是在12世纪初写作的，那就是蒙茅斯的杰弗里（Geoffrey of Monmouth）。所以这是劳拉·劳森（Laura Lawson）的问题，劳拉·劳森，我想我们现在应该讨论一些问题了，是的，因为你和我可以谈论亚瑟王好几个小时，我的意思是，也许大家听得很开心，但我们俩自己大概能唠叨好几天。
But Laura Lawson says, basically, how is it, how much is it Geoffrey of Monmouth's creation? And you think it is, right? I think it's, Geoffrey of Monmouth is absolutely hugely influential. He is constructing, he's writing a history of the kings of britain and it's jeffrey monmouth who gives the kind of the entire narrative from brutus the trojan escaping the sack of troy coming to britain killing all the drag killing all the giants um establishing his kingdom and that gives you a sense of the kind of the quality of the accuracy um and it has to be and he gives us a lot of the familiar story that we now know so right he is the guy who weaves in the story of arthur with vortigern with the
但劳拉·劳森说，基本上，这在多大程度上是蒙茅斯的杰弗里创造的？你认为是的，对吧？我认为是的，蒙茅斯的杰弗里具有绝对巨大的影响力。他在构建，他在撰写一部不列颠诸王史，正是蒙茅斯的杰弗里给出了完整的叙事：从特洛伊的布鲁图斯（Brutus）逃脱特洛伊陷落、来到不列颠、杀死所有的巨龙、杀死所有的巨人、建立他的王国，这让你对准确性的质量有了一个概念，而且必须是这样，他给我们提供了许多我们现在所熟知的熟悉的故事，没错，他就是将亚瑟的故事与伏提庚、
arrival of hengist and horser with merlin um with the uh this idea of a golden age um where arthur becomes the king of the whole of britain um he invades uh roman gaul he becomes the kind of emperor on the continent as well so he's an all-conquering kind of superhero and then there is the um the war between mordred and arthur that um ends with arthur's uh death perhaps um and uh that then um after arthur's death then uh the britain's everything goes wrong for them but i think that what is interesting why is jeffrey of monmouth what's he doing with this okay so the last sentence of his history he ends it with the reign of athelstan and athelstan is the anglo--Saxon king who joins all the various
亨吉斯特和霍萨（Hengist and Horsa）的到来、梅林、黄金时代的观点编织在一起的人，在黄金时代中亚瑟成为了整个不列颠的国王，他入侵罗马高卢，也成为了欧洲大陆上的某种皇帝，所以他是一个无所不能的超级英雄，然后还有莫德雷德和亚瑟之间的战争，以亚瑟的死亡（也许吧）告终，然后，在亚瑟死后，不列颠人一切都开始走下坡路。但我认为有趣的是，为什么蒙茅斯的杰弗里要这样做？好吧，他的历史的最后一句，他以阿特尔斯坦（Athelstan）的统治结束，阿特尔斯坦是那个将各个
Anglo-Saxon kingdoms together to forge the kingdom of England. But he also claims the supremacy over the whole of Britain. He says he's the king of all of Britain, including the Welsh princes, including all the various kings of what will become Scotland. And Athelstan is a king who is appropriating the Roman traditions as well. So he holds kind of great derbars in Roman cities and he summons kings from across Britain. Does he use the word emperor, Tom? Yes, he does. Yes. So he's an imperator, he's a rex, he's all these kind of qualities. And I think it's telling that that jeffrey monmouth finishes
盎格鲁-撒克逊王国联合起来铸造英格兰王国的盎格鲁-撒克逊国王。但他同时也声称对整个不列颠拥有至高无上的权力。他说他是全不列颠的国王，包括威尔士诸侯，包括日后将成为苏格兰的各种国王。阿特尔斯坦也是一位同样在挪用罗马传统的国王。因此他在罗马城市举行盛大的朝觐（durbar），并召集来自全不列颠的国王。他用“皇帝”这个词吗，汤姆？是的，他用了。是的。所以他是一个英白拉多（imperator），他是一个国王（rex），他具备所有这些品质。我认为很有说明意义的是，蒙茅斯的杰弗里以
with athelstan because in a sense what he's doing is back projecting athelstan's achievements onto the figure of arthur right so i think that arthur is a kind of a britannized athelstan if you like he's he's an emperor who rules over the whole of britain who is the heir to roman traditions um who achieves great things and defeats his enemies and i think essentially that that's what's going on and i think as well it's telling that there are welsh writers who are aware that this is absolute nonsense there's g's Gerald of Wales, splendidly named Gerald of Wales, who describes a man who's possessed by devils. And he says that when the gospels are placed on the chest of this possessed man, the devils flee away. But if you put a copy of Geoffrey of Monmouth's history on his chest, all the devils come flocking back. That's historians, that's just historians being bitchy about each other, isn't it?
阿特尔斯坦结束，因为在某种程度上，他所做的是将阿特尔斯坦的成就投射回亚瑟身上，没错，所以我觉得亚瑟有点像一个不列颠化了的阿特尔斯坦，如果你愿意这么说的话，他是一个统治全不列颠的皇帝，是罗马传统的继承人，他取得了伟大的成就并击败了敌人，我认为本质上这就是正在发生的事情。而且我认为同样具有说明意义的是，有一些威尔士作家意识到这纯属无稽之谈，比如威尔士的吉拉德（Gerald of Wales），名字非常棒的威尔士吉拉德，他描述了一个被恶魔附身的人。他说，当福音书被放在这个被附身之人的胸口时，恶魔就逃跑了。但如果你把一本蒙茅斯的杰弗里的历史书放在他胸口，所有的恶魔都会蜂拥回来。这就是历史学家，历史学家就是喜欢刻薄地评价彼此，对吧？
Yes. So there's a kind of kickback against the fact that Geoffrey is writing history. But obviously, you know, people have a stake. The Welsh have a stake in it. So they're generally quite keen on it. And of course, the kings of England have a stake in it. Because if Arthur was the king of the whole of Britain, then obviously that's quite useful if you're a norman king wanting to conquer the welsh wanting to conquer the scots and because
是的。所以这里存在一种针对杰弗里在写历史这一事实的反弹。但显然，你知道，人们有利益相关。威尔士人在这其中有利益相关。所以他们通常相当热衷于它。当然，英格兰的国王们在这其中也有利益相关。因为如果亚瑟是全不列颠的国王，那么显然，如果你是一个想要征服威尔士、想要征服苏格兰的诺曼国王，这就非常有用，而且因为
arthur had invaded um and conquered much of the roman empire according to jeffrey monmouth it's also quite useful if you want to launch a continental invasion so that's the essentially the kind of the context for for arthur that we get by the middle ages um he he's a he's of use to the kings of england and so that's the point at which i guess he gets then he gets picked up by the courtly kind of tradition doesn't he chrétien de toit and then malory and all the rest of it but you did there's one thing we haven't gone into um so this has started to come up a lot in recent years. We have a question from Killing Me Softly.
根据蒙茅斯的杰弗里所说，亚瑟曾入侵并征服了罗马帝国的大部分领土，如果你想发动一场对欧洲大陆的入侵，这也是相当有用的，所以这基本上就是我们在中世纪得到的关于亚瑟的背景，他——他对比起英格兰的国王们是有用的，所以这就是我猜他随后被宫廷传统所吸收的节点，克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦（Chrétien de Troyes），然后是马洛里（Malory）及其他所有人，但你确实漏掉了一点我们没有深入探讨的，嗯，所以在近年来这开始频繁出现。我们有一个来自“杀死我温柔”（Killing Me Softly）的问题。
I know who he is. He's a TV producer called Mick McAvoy. And he says, there's a lot of evidence. He says that King Arthur was from Scotland. We have a Ben Arthur and Arthur's seat. Merlin has been linked to the ancient royal family based at Dumbarton Rock. So was King Arthur Scottish?
我知道他是谁。他是一个名叫米克·麦卡沃伊（Mick McAvoy）的电视制片人。他说，有很多证据。他说亚瑟王来自苏格兰。我们有本亚瑟（Ben Arthur）和亚瑟之座（Arthur's Seat）。梅林与驻扎在敦巴顿岩（Dumbarton Rock）的古代王室有关联。所以亚瑟王是苏格兰人吗？
How unlike a Scottish listener to write something that's Scottish and that the English have stolen it, or indeed the Welsh have stolen it. So do you think, or is that, well, one answer might be that Scottish and Welsh are kind of the same in this period, that there's no clear distinction between the two would that be completely untoward tom well the the welsh speakers who give us this early romance where you this this epic where you get he was no arthur yeah i mean they're welsh speakers um so those traditions the traditions of arthur the traditions of a great warlord who fought the angles and the saxons that's um as true if you're a welsh speaker, you know, Dumbarton,
一个苏格兰听众写下带有苏格兰色彩的东西、并认为英格兰人偷走了它，或者确实是威尔士人偷走了它，这是多么不令人意外啊。所以你认为，或者那是，嗯，一个答案可能是苏格兰人和威尔士人在这一时期有点是一回事，两者之间没有清晰的区别，这种说法完全不合时宜吗，汤姆？嗯，讲威尔士语的人给我们留下了早期传奇，在这里你会得到这是一首他不是亚瑟的史诗，是的，我的意思是他们是讲威尔士语的——所以这些传统，亚瑟的传统，一个与盎格鲁人和萨克逊人作战的伟大军阀的传统，如果你讲威尔士语，那就是真的，你知道，敦巴顿，
the great rock of Dumbarton, as it is if you're in what we'd now call Wales. So in that sense, I think, yes, Arthur is a kind of mythic figure for all those who are speaking kind of variants of Welsh. But what, of course, what becomes the Kingdom of Scotland, you know, it's not, the Scots are not interested in Arthur. So it's complex. So the Cornish obviously claim... I mean, did the Bretons have sometimes made exaggerated claims to Arthur?
敦巴顿巨岩，就像你在我们现在称之为威尔士的地方一样。所以在某种程度上，我认为，是的，亚瑟对于所有那些讲某种威尔士语变体的人来说是一个神话人物。但当然，后来成为苏格兰王国的东西，你知道，它不是，苏格兰人对亚瑟不感兴趣。所以情况很复杂。因此康沃尔人显然声称……我的意思是，布列塔尼人有时也对亚瑟提出过夸张的主张吗？
But what about the Cornish? So that's... You go to Cornwall on holiday and you sort of... There's always this Arthurian sort of legend hanging over you the whole time, isn't there? It's a place of standing stones and ruins and obviously Tintagel. We had lots of questions about Tintagel. Yes, we got one from Alan Andrew Wild,
但康沃尔人呢？所以那是……你去康沃尔度假，你会某种程度上……那种亚瑟王传说一直萦绕在你心头，不是吗？那是一个充满立石和废墟的地方，显然还有廷塔杰尔（Tintagel）。我们有很多关于廷塔杰尔的问题。是的，我们有一个来自阿兰·安德鲁·怀德（Alan Andrew Wild）的问题，
who asks how much of Arthur's connection to Tintagel is history versus legend? And I think this is a fascinating question because it goes to the heart of this kind of weird nexus, this web of history and myth and folklore and the the late antique and the medieval and the modern attitudes to arthur um and so having said that let's have a break um delayed gratification we'll come back to it uh after we listen to the adverts i'm marina hyde and i'm richard os Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
他问亚瑟与廷塔杰尔的联系中，有多少是历史，多少是传说？我认为这是一个迷人的问题，因为它直击这种奇怪的交汇点核心，直击历史、神话、民间传说与晚期古代、中世纪以及现代对亚瑟态度的网络核心，有鉴于此，让我们休息一下，延迟满足，听完广告后我们再回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
评论、八卦猛料的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History
我们正翘首以待汤姆·霍兰德关于廷塔杰尔的解答。我迫不及待了。汤姆，告诉我们，廷塔杰尔是真的吗？是的，那么亚瑟与廷塔杰尔有什么联系？根据传说，那是亚瑟被孕育的地方，是的，而乌瑟·潘德拉贡（Uther Pendragon），亚瑟的父亲，爱上了伊格兰（Igraine），她嗯，是康沃尔公爵的妻子，而乌瑟作为一个冲动的人，立刻去围攻了
and we are poised for an answer from Tom Holland all about Tintagel. I can't wait. Tom, tell us, is Tintagel real? Yeah, so what's Arthur's connection to Tintagel? According to the legend,'s where arthur is conceived yeah and uther pendragon arthur's father has fallen in love with igraine who is um the the wife of the duke of cornwall and uther being um an impetuous man immediately goes and besieges
廷塔杰尔，梅林前来，为他提供途径去接近伊格兰，而康沃尔公爵丈夫不在家。他死了，乌瑟得到了伊格兰，亚瑟就被孕育了。他难道不是在伪装吗？乌瑟难道不是伪装着吗？是的，他伪装成她的丈夫。是的，没错，是的。这就是故事。行为恶劣，汤姆。
tintagel uh merlin comes offers him access to uh igraineraine while the Duke of Cornwall husband is away. He dies, Uther gets to Igraine, and Arthur is conceived. Is he not in disguise? Isn't Uther not disguised? Yes, he's disguised as her husband. Yes, that's right, yeah. So that's the story. Poor behaviour, Tom.
行为确实非常恶劣，是的，非常恶劣。而且廷塔杰尔还与更多恶劣行为联系在一起，嗯，特里斯坦和伊索尔德的传说，是的，他去寻找爱尔兰公主，把她带回那里，康沃尔正在发生抢夺妇女的事情，所以这就是，这就是那种联系——它是怎么产生的呢？确实在5和6世纪，廷塔杰尔似乎是一个主要中心，所以有各种各样的证据表明与罗马世界有贸易往来，没错，所以也许有一种民间记忆的遗产解释了为什么亚瑟与它联系在一起，但真正让廷塔杰尔成为一种浪漫中世纪城堡的标志性形象的原因，是因为它在中世纪就是这样的，因为它被赠予了亨利三世的兄弟
Very poor behaviour, yes, very poor behaviour. And also Tintagel is associated with more poor behavior um the legend of tristan and exalt um yes who goes to get the irish princess brings her back there are women stealing going on in cornwall so so that's the that's the kind of that's the connection um how did it come about it is the case that in the fifth and sixth centuries tintagel seems to have been a major center so there are all kinds of um evidence for trade with the roman world right and that is so maybe there's a kind of a legacy of folk memories of that which explains why arthur is linked to it but really the reason why tintagel is the kind of emblematic image of a kind of romantic medieval castle is because that's what it was in the middle ages because it gets given to a brother of henry iii
理查德，他成为了康沃尔伯爵理查德，他基本上搬进了廷塔杰尔，并建造了我们现在在那里看到的城堡。甚至在他建造它的时候，它也是一种有意识的复古风格。对。是的。本质上，康沃尔的理查德建造廷塔杰尔，是为了让它看起来像他想象中亚瑟王城堡应该有的样子。从某种意义上说，你会在亚瑟王神话中一遍又一遍地看到这一点，那就是人们不断地构建它应该是什么样子的形象。而且真的，这种事直到今天仍在继续，因为最近在那里的考古发掘中，他们发现了一块罗马石头，上面有一个铭文，可能提到了一个叫阿托格努（Artognu）的人。哦，汤姆，你还在否认亚瑟是真的吗？难以置信。
richard who becomes richard duke of cornwall and he basically moves in on tintagel and builds the castle that we see there now and even when he building it, it was in a kind of consciously retro style. Right. Yeah. Essentially, Richard Cornwall is building Tintagel to look like he imagines an Arthurian castle should look. And in a sense, that's what you get over and over with the Arthurian myths is people constantly constructing images of what it should look like. And really, it's still going on to this day because recent excavations there, they found a lump of Roman stone and there was an inscription on it that perhaps mentioned someone called Artognu. Oh, Tom, you're still denying Arthur was real? Unbelievable.
好吧，所以这里有各种各样的问题。那不是亚瑟。那是，你知道，他叫阿托格努。但英国遗产委员会（English Heritage）发布了一份新闻稿说，哇，这就是亚瑟。从某种意义上说，他们所做的事与中世纪人们所做的事完全一样，不仅在廷塔杰尔，特别是在格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury），那里的格拉斯顿伯里的僧侣们，你知道的，
Right, so there are all kinds of problems. It's not Arthur. It's, you know, he's called our dog name. But the English Heritage put out a press release saying, Whoa, it is Arthur. And in a sense, what they're doing there is exactly what people were doing in the Middle Ages, not just at Tintagel, but particularly Glastonbury, where the monks at Glastonbury, you know,
他们在捏造与亚瑟的联系，因为这会吸引游客。而本质上，英国遗产委员会当他们说“是的，这表明亚瑟曾在这里存在”时，他们基本上也在做同样的事情。因为当然，那是，你知道，事实是亚瑟很卖座。我的意思是……是的，当然。当然。好吧，让我们专门谈谈亚瑟，因为我们有大量关于亚瑟作为一个神话式人物的问题。所以我们开始吧。尼尔上校（Colonel Neil）说，我认为说得对，亚瑟王难道不像许多其他国家的民间神话英雄吗——当土地处于危急存亡时，他们会等待时机再次崛起并保卫这片土地？比如爱尔兰的芬·麦库尔（Finn McCool）或德国的齐格弗里德（Siegfried），喜欢这个播客，他说道。
they're manufacturing the links with Arthur because it will bring in tourists. And essentially English heritage, when they're saying, yes, this shows that Arthur existed here, basically they're doing the same. Because of course, that's, you know, the truth is that Arthur sells. I mean... Yeah, of course. Of course. Well, let's talk about Arthur specifically, because we had tons of questions about Arthur as a sort of mythic figure. So let's kick off. Colonel Neil, he says, I think rightly, isn't King Arthur similar to a lot of other nations' mythical figures who lay waiting to arise and defend the land when it's in peril? So Finn McCool in Ireland or Siegfried in Germany, love the podcast, he says
说得非常对。谢谢。但这确实是真的，对吧，汤姆？亚瑟与其说是一个个体，不如说是一个原型。是的，嗯，他成为了某个将会再次降临并拯救我们的人的象征，是的，显然在过去的几年里，相当多的人一直在想他什么时候才会出现，是的，但我的意思是，甚至在嗯，在英格兰，我们也有德雷克（Drake），不是吗？我们有德雷克的鼓。嗯，尼莫（Nemo）有一个问题，这是一个送给你的礼物，汤姆，所以尼莫问，亚瑟王的传奇与另一个复活的英雄耶稣基督之间有什么相似之处？你认为这些相似之处是刻意为之的吗？所以你认为亚瑟王的故事是模仿基督的故事吗？
quite rightly. Thank you. But that's true, isn't it, Tom? Arthur is an archetype, really, rather than an individual. Yes, well, becomes the emblem of um someone who will come again and and save us and yeah obviously over the past few years quite a lot of people wondering when he's going to turn up yeah um but i mean even in even in uh in england we've got drake as well haven't we got drake's drum well nemo has a question that is which is just a gift to you tom so nemo says what are the parallels between the legend of King Arthur and another resurrected hero, Jesus Christ? And do you think these similarities are deliberate? So do you think the Arthurian story was kind of modelled on the story of Christ?
其中有某种真相吗？不，我不这么认为。我不这么认为。我认为，嗯，不，我认为这关乎，嗯，在某种程度上，关于亚瑟再次归来的故事，与中世纪盎格鲁-威尔士政治的纠葛绑在一起。因为是威尔士人在谈论亚瑟将如何再次归来，也许吧，并把现在是英格兰、但曾经是不列颠的土地还给他们。
Is there some truth in that? No, I don't think so. I don't think so. I think, well, no, I think it's about, well, in a way, the story about Arthur coming again is tied up with the snarl of Anglo-Welsh politics in the Middle Ages. Because it's the Welsh who talk about how Arthur will come again, perhaps, and give them back what's now England, but was Britain.
所以英格兰的国王们，你知道，他们不希望那样。爱德华一世（Edward I）尤其如此，他最终将征服威尔士，他对亚瑟归来的想法完全不感兴趣。但同样地，爱德华对作为统治整个不列颠之人的亚瑟这一模版非常感兴趣。因此，正是在爱德华统治时期，格拉斯顿伯里才聚焦于发现亚瑟的坟墓。僧侣们某种程度上奇迹般地发现了它以及他的王后吉娜薇（Guinevere）的墓。并且有盛大的排场和庆祝活动，亚瑟的坟墓被移动并供奉起来，但这也非常方便，对吧，是在英格兰找到的，是在
And so the kings of England, you know, they don't want that. And Edward I, in particular, who will end up conquering Wales, is massively not interested in the idea of Arthur coming back again. But equally, Edward is very interested in the model of Arthur as someone who rules the whole of Britain. So it's in Edward's reign that you get the focus at Glastonbury on the discovery of Arthur's tomb. The monks kind of miraculously discover it and the grave of Guinevere, his queen. And there's great kind of pomp and celebration and and arthur's grave gets moved and enshrined but it's also very it's convenient right that it's in england that they found it in
英格兰而不是在，是的，威尔士或康沃尔或，是的，这极其方便，因为本质上爱德华试图做的是，保留那个征服全不列颠的亚瑟，同时摆脱那个会再次归来的亚瑟，是的，而且僧侣们在这其中有巨大的利益相关，因为基本上格拉斯顿伯里没有多少圣物，它没有，嗯，大量人们想看的东西，所以通过发现亚瑟的墓，他们也在发明一个摇钱树。因此，就爱德华和格拉斯顿伯里的僧侣而言，皆大欢喜。但那个传统某种程度上挥之不去，并在马洛里那里得到了最有力、最令人难忘的表达，他说：是的，你知道，亚瑟最终被埋葬在格拉斯顿伯里，但人们确实说他将再次归来。他引述了那句著名的短语：“昔日与未来的国王”（rex quondam rexque futurus）。
england and not in yes wales or cornwall or yeah it it's incredibly convenient because essentially what edward is trying to do is to is to have the the arthur who conquers the whole of britain while getting rid of the arthur who will come again yeah um and the monks have a massive stake in this because basically glastonbury doesn't have many relics it doesn't have um a huge amount of stuff that people want to see so by discovering arthur's tomb they are inventing a cash cow as well so as far as edward and the monks at glastonbury concerned everyone's a winner but that that tradition kind of lingers on and it's expressed most force you know most memorably in mallory where he he says yes you know arthur ended up being buried at glastonbury but men do say that he will come again and he quotes his famous phrase rex quondam rex quae futuris the
但这很有趣，因为那个，那个想法被第一代都铎王朝采纳了，他们显然有威尔士血统，所以当亨利·都铎（Henry Tudor）在米尔福德黑文（Milford Haven）登陆并向博斯沃思（Bosworth）进军时，他在穿过威尔士时有人谈论他是新的亚瑟，因为这能让他招募军队，然后亨利八世热爱所有关于亚瑟的东西，正是亨利八世为你在温彻斯特看到的这个巨大的圆桌支付了费用，这是他在神圣罗马帝国皇帝查理五世（Charles V）访问时制作的。他想炫耀它，并把自己展示为新的亚瑟。他的第一任妻子阿拉贡的凯瑟琳（Catherine of Aragon）是在格拉纳达的阿尔罕布拉宫（Alhambra）阅读亚瑟的故事长大的。所以在那个时候，亚瑟已经是一个国际品牌，如果你是一个宫廷式的、崇尚骑士精神的人，你就会去接受它。
once and future king but it's interesting because that that i that idea was taken up by the first tudors who obviously had welsh lineage so when henry tudor has landed at milford haven and he's marching to bosworth there's talk of him as the new arthur as he's going across wales because it'll allow him to recruit troops and then henry the eighth loved all the stuff about arthur and it's hen Henry VIII who paid for this big round table that you see in Winchester, which he had done when Charles V, the Holy Roman Emperor, was visiting. He wanted to show it off and to show himself off as the new Arthur. Catherine of Aragon, his first wife, had grown up reading stories of Arthur in the Alhambra in Granada. So by that time, Arthur was this international brand that you sort of bought into
而且我认为温彻斯特那张桌子上画的亚瑟形象，也是刻意设计来唤起亨利八世的形象的。我的意思是，那张桌子的起源，我认为，可以追溯到爱德华一世的统治时期。而且它，你知道，爱德华本质上是把它作为一个模型来建造的。而到了爱德华一世统治时期，以及到了爱德华三世统治时期，它已经被视为字面意义上的圆桌了。是的，一个圆桌。所以，是的，当然，亨利八世的哥哥就叫亚瑟。有趣的事情之一是，威尔士亲王定期被称为亚瑟，而他们都死了。
if you were a sort of courtly, chivalrous kind of person. And I think the image of Arthur that's painted on that table in Winchester is consciously designed to evoke the image of Henry VIII as well. I mean, the origins of that table, I think, again, goes back to Edward I's reign. And it's, you know, Edward is essentially building it as a model. And by the time to Edward I's reign, and Edward is essentially building it as a model. And by the time of Edward III's reign, it's come to be seen as the literal round table. Yeah, a round table. So, yes, and of course, Henry VIII's elder brother was called Arthur. And one of the interesting things is that periodically you get Princes of Wales being called Arthur, and they all die.
只有真正的亚瑟，汤姆。只有真正的亚瑟才能……是的。无论如何，我们有大量的问题。让我们来一个关于剑的问题。马修·德雷克（Matthew Drake）说，我小时候看过《神剑》（Excalibur），也许是在太小的年纪，但我会带着我的封城小狗散步并收听这个节目，我想知道这把剑背后的任何神秘传说是否属实，如果它存在，它现在在哪里休息？
Only the real Arthur, Tom. Only the real Arthur can... Yeah. Anyway, we've got tons of questions. Let's have another one about the sword. Matthew Drake, he says, I watched Excalibur at a boy, perhaps at way too young an age, but I will be walking my lockdown puppy listening to this and I want to know if any of the mystery behind the sword is true
所以埃克斯卡利伯（Excalibur）是从哪里来的？人们经常认为埃克斯卡利伯和石中剑是同一把剑，当然它们不是，它们是两把不同的剑。汤姆，大致在什么时候，这两把剑进入了故事？它们一定某种程度上是中世纪盛期的发明，对吧？是的，所以亚瑟有各种各样的剑，著名的传说是由湖中仙女（Lady of the Lake）赐予他的。然后当他死后，对此著名的描述又是在马洛里那里。坦尼森（Tennyson）对其进行了精彩的重述。贝狄威尔爵士（Sir Bedivere）拿起剑并将它扔了回去。
and if it exists, where does it rest? so where does the Excalibur come so Excalibur people often think Excalibur and the sword and stone are the same thing which of course they're not they're two different swords at what roughly at what point Tom do those two swords enter the story they must be sort of you know high middle ages inventions are they yes so Arthur has kind of various swords and the famous legend is that he is given it by the Lady of the Lake. And then when he dies, the famous account of that is in Mallory again. And it gets retold brilliantly by Tennyson. Sir Bedivere takes the sword and hurls it back.
如果它存在，它又在哪里？那么“王者之剑”是从哪里来的？人们通常认为“王者之剑”和“石中剑”是同一把剑，当然它们不是，它们是两把不同的剑。汤姆，这两把剑大约在什么时候进入故事的？它们一定可以说是中世纪盛期的发明吗？是的，亚瑟有各种各样的剑，最著名的传说是由湖中仙子赐予他的。然后当他死去时，最著名的记载又见于马洛里的小说中。丁尼生对此进行了精彩的重新演绎。贝狄威尔爵士拿起剑，把它扔了回去。
And the hand dressed in white samite comes from the water and takes the sword and plunges back in um and that's what inspires the famous modbython joke in the holy grail about strange women lying in ponds distributing swords um being considered a reasonable basis for a system of government um but actually the joke points at the way in which swords are politically potent. So although you have this story that Arthur's sword Excalibur has vanished, and presumably when he comes again, he will have it at his side. Actually, there are other traditions that these swords are kind of relics that can be taken and used by people who need them. And the famous example of that is richard the lionheart who um is spectacularly not interested in king arthur because he takes this sword and when he meets
那只套着白色锁子甲手套的手从水中伸出来，拿走了宝剑，然后又潜了下去。嗯，这也启发了《圣杯》中那个著名的巨蟒剧团笑话：池中怪妇分发宝剑，嗯，被认为是政府合法性来源的一个合理依据。但实际上，这个笑话指出了宝剑在政治上具有潜力的这种方式。所以，尽管你有这样一个故事，亚瑟王的宝剑“誓约胜利之剑”已经消失了，据推测，当他再次归来时，它会陪伴在他身侧。实际上，还有其他传统认为，这些宝剑某种程度上是圣物，可以被需要它们的人拿去使用。其中一个著名的例子就是狮心王理查，他，嗯，对亚瑟王极其不感兴趣，因为他拿走了这把剑，当他遇到
up with the um with the uh the king of sicily and um the king of sicily gives him kind of various gifts and richard the lionheart gives him king arthur's sword oh no he gives it away yeah yeah basically he's doing it because it's kind of massive one-arm friendship. Nobody can compete with King Arthur's sword. I mean, it really puts the King of Sicily in his place. I like to imagine him travelling with this huge cupboard full of King Arthur's swords.
西西里国王时，嗯，西西里国王送给了他各种各样的礼物，而狮心王理查把亚瑟王的宝剑送给了他——哦不，他把它送人了！对，对，基本上他这么做是因为这是一种巨大的、单方面的友谊展示。没有人能与亚瑟王的宝剑相提并论。我的意思是，这确实让西西里国王相形见绌、知道了自己的分量。我喜欢想象他带着一个装满了亚瑟王宝剑的巨大橱柜四处旅行。
You know, like sort of monastic relics or something. He's giving out to kings left, right and centre. Yes, yes. So, again, it's kind of a bit like the body of Arthur. You know, is the body of Arthur at Glastonbury
你知道的，就像某种修道院的圣物之类的。他把剑左手、右手、居中地分发给各个国王。是的，是的。所以，这又有点像亚瑟王的遗体。你知道的，亚瑟王的遗体是在格拉斯顿伯里
or is he in the Isle of Avalon waiting to come again? And likewise, is Arthur's sword in the lake with the Lady of the Lake waiting to be handed out again when he comes back?
还是在阿瓦隆岛等待再次归来？同样，亚瑟王的宝剑是在湖里与湖中妖女在一起，等待着他归来时再次被分发出来？
Or is it something that Riz Zalanhart can give away as a kind of... Is it in some mafia boss's house in Sicily in Corleone
还是说它可以被狮心王理查当作某种……它此时此刻就挂在西西里科莱昂某个黑手党老大的家里？
as we speak? But obviously, it's had a huge afterlife, hasn't it? I mean, the two examples I can think of are the sword that was broken in The Lord of the Rings, so Anduril, Aragorn's sword, which identifies him as the king. And the one that most people are familiar with, which is Luke Skywalker's lightsaber, which is given in Star Wars. And it's his inheritance. What, a sword of power?
但很显然，它有着巨大的后世影响，不是吗？我的意思是，我能想到的两个例子是《指环王》中被折断的剑，也就是安都瑞尔，阿拉贡的剑，它证明了他的国王身份。另一个是大多数人都熟悉的，也就是《星球大战》中给卢克·天行者的光剑。那是他的传承。什么？一把权力的剑？
It's inheritance from Darth Vader. You know, only he can wield it. And actually, Star Wars, the first Star Wars film, you know, the original, as we would know it, basically is an Arthurian story. The boy who's been adopted, who wields the sword and rediscovers his inheritance. I mean, in a way, that's actually Harry Potter on his wand. It's the sort of... That's the interesting thing about the Arthurian story, to me,
这是从达斯·维达那里继承来的。你知道的，只有他能挥舞它。事实上，《星球大战》，第一部《星球大战》电影，你知道的，正如我们所熟知的原版，基本上就是一个亚瑟王的故事。那个被收养的男孩，挥舞着宝剑，重新发现了他的身世传承。从某种意义上说，这实际上就是哈利·波特和他的魔杖。这就是那种……这就是亚瑟王故事对我的吸引力所在，
the fact that it's had this immense cultural footprint. Well, there's a good question here from Chris Cope, who asked, why is there such an enduring interest in this story? And, you know, you've written a lot about the power of popular stories, and particularly British popular stories. What do you think the source of the power is?
也就是它拥有巨大的文化影响力。嗯，克里斯·科普（Chris Cope）在这里提出了一个很好的问题，他问：为什么人们对这个故事会有如此持久的兴趣？而且，你知道的，你写了很多关于大众故事力量的文章，尤其是英国大众故事。你认为这种力量的源泉是什么？
Well, Freud had this, Freud claimed that there was this thing called, I think he called it the family romance, though people will correct me if I'm wrong. He said children, when they reach an age, they reach an age of about 9, 10, 11, and boys particularly, when they fantasise, as part of their sort of breaking away from their parents, they fantasise that they're adopted
嗯，弗洛伊德有这样一个观点，弗洛伊德声称存在着这样一种东西，我想他称之为“家庭传奇”，尽管如果我错了的话，大家会纠正我的。他说孩子们，当他们到达一个年龄，大概是9岁、10岁、11岁时，尤其是男孩，当他们幻想时——作为他们摆脱父母羁绊的一部分——他们会幻想自己是被收养的，
or that their real parents are somebody else. And they they often fantasize, they have a daydream that they are the children of rich and powerful people, and they have this hidden inheritance. Maybe that's about the point in your sort of growing up, that you become, you know, conscious of disappointments, or loneliness, or whatever, and you begin to create this sort of dream world for yourself. And you imagine that you've been disappointed by life and your true role lies somewhere else. And I think that's one of the key things to the Arthur story, isn't it? It's that the bit that people always remember is the story of the boy
或者他们的亲生父母是别的什么人。他们经常幻想，会做一个白日梦，梦想自己是权贵之家的孩子，并且拥有隐藏的继承权。也许这大约正是你成长到某个阶段时的表现，你开始意识到失望、孤独或诸如此类的事情，并开始为自己创造这样一个梦想世界。你想象自己被生活所辜负，你真正的角色在别处。我认为这是亚瑟王故事的关键点之一，不是吗？人们永远记得的那部分，其实是一个男孩的故事，
who is overlooked and downtrodden by, you know, pushed around by Kay, who he has to be a squire for but that's that's because of th white isn't it i mean that's the sword in the stone and yeah but that's that's i think what kids often get in and then and then of course he has all the adventures and all the rest of it but i think the point at which kids the the thing that adults like and kids probably don't like is um lancelot and guinevere you know my my son sort of said just describes that very dismissively as the love and so he likes he loves all king arthur but he can't stand the love and i think that's the bit that obviously fascinated the pre-rephilites you know
他被凯（Kay）忽视、受尽践踏、被呼来喝去，他不得不为凯当一名侍从……但那是因为白骑士，对吧？我的意思是，那是《石中剑》里的情节。是的，但我觉得那是孩子们通常最先接触到的，然后，当然了，他经历所有的冒险以及其他种种。但我认为，孩子们……成年人喜欢、而孩子们可能不喜欢的地方在于，嗯，兰斯洛特和吉尼薇儿，你知道的，我的儿子曾非常轻蔑地把它描述为“爱情故事”，所以他喜欢关于亚瑟王的一切，但他受不了爱情部分。我认为正是这一点显然让拉斐尔前派着迷，你知道的，
this sort of doomed romance and all that sort of side of things and they're sort of drippy maidens and stuff um drippy maidens but why but i don't know what a lot yeah well i mean they're all sort of one thing by that point but why do you think it's lasted so long tom i mean why does it have this hold on the cultural imagination well i i think the ideal of camelelot, as you'll know, I mean, you know, Jackie Kennedy. Kennedy, yeah, Kennedy's. Described her husband's court as Camelot. The idea of a golden age where nights are bold, the glamour of it, the colour of it, the excitement of it um and then when that's combined with the tragic arc of arthur's story and this kind of tantalizing sense that it might come back again i think it's incredibly powerful powerful narrative and actually i do think that the story of lancelot and guinevere
这种注定的浪漫情调以及所有这类事情，还有那些柔弱的少女之类的人……柔弱的少女，但是为什么……我不知道很多，好吧，我的意思是到那个时候它们都是一种东西了。但汤姆，你认为为什么它能持续这么久？我的意思是，为什么它对文化想象力有如此大的控制力？嗯，我认为卡米洛特的理想，正如你所知道的，我的意思是，你知道的，杰奎琳·肯尼迪。肯尼迪，对，肯尼迪的（把她丈夫的宫廷描述为卡米洛特）。一个骑士英勇无畏的黄金时代的概念，它的魅力，它的色彩，它的刺激感，然后当它与亚瑟王故事的悲剧弧线相结合时，以及这种挥之不去的感觉：他可能还会归来，我认为这是一个具有不可思议力量的叙事。事实上，我的确认为兰斯洛特和吉尼薇儿的故事
is a crucial part of it um it certainly was in the middle ages because in a sense lancelot is i mean he's a kind of tragic figure because he he wants to be the very best that he can at everything so he wants to be the best knight the truest knight the truest knight to his liege lord and he wants to be the truest lover um so he is completely true to guinevere arthur's wife and that's the kind of the the tragedy is that he can't be both and so he fails to win the grail and then his his romance with guinevere ends up sundering the round table and it leads to the civil war that results in arthur's death or his departure to the isle of avalon or whatever and so the sense that the round table is destroyed by something that is noble and heroic,
是其中的关键部分。在的中世纪绝对是这样，因为从某种意义上说，兰斯洛特是一个悲剧人物，因为他希望在每件事上都做到最好：他想成为最优秀的骑士、最忠诚的骑士、对他的封君最忠诚的骑士，他还想成为最忠诚的情人，所以他对亚瑟王的妻子吉尼薇儿绝对忠诚。悲剧就在于他无法兼顾这两者，因此他没能赢得圣杯，然后他与吉尼薇儿的浪漫恋情最终分裂了圆桌骑士团，并导致了内战，最终导致了亚瑟王的死亡，或是他前往阿瓦隆岛等等。因此，圆桌骑士团被某种高贵而英勇的事物所毁灭的感觉，
i.e. Lancelot's desire to be the best, I think is powerful. And actually, I've copied this out because it's one of my absolute favourite passages of prose, and I don't think that we've had enough amazing passages of prose on this. Tom hasn't done enough recitals. It's from Mallory's, Mork D'Arthur Mallory, writes the kind of, you know,
也就是兰斯洛特渴望做到最好的愿望，我认为这极具感染力。事实上，我把这段话抄了下来，因为这是我绝对最喜欢的散文段落之一，而且我觉得我们在这方面还没有读到足够多精彩的散文段落。汤姆还没有做够朗诵。这是出自马洛里的《亚瑟王之死》，马洛里在15世纪玫瑰战争的背景下，写下了可以说是……
the definitive summing up of the Arthurian romances in the 15th century against the backdrop of the Wars of the Roses. And this is Sir Hector, Lancelot's brother, who, when Lancelot dies, delivers this incredibly powerful threnody to him this kind of obituary um our Lancelot he said thou were head of all Christian knights and now I dare say said Sir Hector thou Sir Lancelot there thou liest that thou were never matched of earthly knight's hand
对亚瑟王传奇最具决定性的总结。这是兰斯洛特的兄弟埃克托爵士（Sir Ector），当兰斯洛特死后，他发表了一篇极其震撼的悼词，也就是这种讣告。我们的兰斯洛特，他说，你曾是所有基督徒骑士的首领，现在我敢说，埃克托爵士说，你，兰斯洛特，你安息在那里，你从未被尘世骑士的之手所匹敌，
and thou were the courteous knight that ever bear shield and thou were the truest friend to thy lover that ever bestrad horse and thou were the truest friend to thy lover that ever bestrad horse. And thou were the truest lover of a sinful man that ever loved woman. And thou were the kindest man that ever struck with sword. And thou were the goodliest person that ever came among press of knights. And thou was the meekest man, the gentlest that ever ate in hall among ladies. And thou were the sternest knight to thy mortal foe that ever put spear in the rest. That's great stuff, isn't it? Yeah, it's great stuff.
你曾是所有持盾者中最温文尔雅的骑士，你曾是骑马者中对爱人最忠诚的朋友，你曾是骑马者中对爱人最忠诚的朋友。你曾是一个罪人对所爱女人最忠诚的情人。你曾是挥剑者中最仁慈的人。你曾是挤在骑士群中最英俊的人。你曾在宫廷贵妇中用餐时最温顺、最温和。你曾是面对生死之敌时、把长矛放上枪托最严厉的骑士。这真是了不起的文字，不是吗？是的，真是了不起的文字。
Fantastic. And I think that that's a model of heroism that, you know, we still are capable of admiring. And doomed heroism, because otherwise it would be nauseating. I mean, the doomedness is... So your punishment for taking over the podcast to start doing long recitals is that I get to read out Bill Jones's question, and Bill Jones says, Send Holland down the Joseph of Arimathea Holy Grail King Arthur Glastonbury Thorn Rabbit Hole. Go on, Tom.
太棒了。我认为这是一种我们依然能够为之赞叹的英雄主义模范。而且是一种注定走向毁灭的英雄主义，否则就会令人作呕。我的意思是，这种注定毁灭的宿命是……所以，你接管播客开始长篇大诵的惩罚就是，我得把比尔·琼斯（Bill Jones）的问题读出来。比尔·琼斯说：“让霍兰德深入阿里马太的约瑟、圣杯、亚瑟王、格拉斯顿伯里刺木的兔子洞吧。”来吧，汤姆。
Down you go, but you must come back. Well, the Holy Grail is part of the kind of romance tradition that we talked about. Chrétien de Troyes writes about it, and then it gets taken up over the course of the Middle Ages. It's assumed to be the cup that Christ drank from at the Last Supper. And it's supposed to have been brought to Britain
跳下去吧，但你必须回来。嗯，圣杯是我们之前谈到的传奇传统的一部分。克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦写过它，然后在整个中世纪被继承下来。人们认为它是基督在最后的晚餐中饮酒的杯子。并且据称它被带到了不列颠，
by Joseph of Arimathea, who in legend comes to be cast as Jesus's uncle. And so that's the root of the story that when Jesus was a young boy, he came with Joseph of Arimathea, who was supposedly a trader. So that's the thing in Jerusalem, did those feet in ancient times. And it comes to be associated with Glastonbury. And again, the monks at Glastonbury prove very, very successful at kind of appropriating these Arthurian legends and these the kind of the hint of the weird um and the the allure of these legends last into the modern age and you can see it in kind of various
带它来的是阿里马太的约瑟，他在传说中被塑造成了耶稣的叔叔。所以这就是那个故事的根源：当耶稣还是个小男孩时，他曾和据说是商人的阿里马太的约瑟一起来过这里。这就是“那些金足在古代岁月里”的典故。它后来与格拉斯顿伯里联系在了一起。同样，格拉斯顿伯里的僧侣们在将这些亚瑟王传说以及那些诡异的暗示……据为己有方面取得了巨大的、巨大的成功。这些传说的魅力一直延续到现代，你可以在各种
ways so you see it for instance in um T.S. Eliot's The Wasteland. The Fisher King. The Fisher King, who supposedly has been struck a dolorous blow, which I think is such a fantastic and with his dolorous blow, all the land has become a wasteland and the attaining of the grail enables the land to be healed. And Eliot picks up on a book by a scholar called jesse weston who has written a book from ritual to romance which casts this as a kind of pagan metaphor that's been christianized and elliot then kind of puts that feeds that into um into the wasteland um but of course it's also there in um uh the film excalibur john bo Borman's film, which is probably, I think, the best cinematic portrayal, serious portrayal of the Arthurian legends.
方式中看到它。比如，你可以在T.S.艾略特的《荒原》中看到它。渔王。传说中遭受了悲惨打击的渔王——我认为这是一个绝妙的构思——由于他遭受的悲惨打击，整片土地变成了一片荒原，而获得圣杯使得这片土地得以疗愈。艾略特借鉴了一位名叫杰西·韦斯顿（Jesse Weston）的学者的书，她写了一本名为《从仪式到浪漫》的书，将这视为一种已被基督教化的异教隐喻，然后艾略特将这些内容融入到了《荒原》之中。当然，它也出现在约翰·布尔曼的电影《神剑》中，我认为这可能是对亚瑟王传奇最好的、最严肃的电影刻画。
You've also got Monty Python, of course, which is slightly less serious. But I think it's also there in the Glastonbury Festival. I think it's a crucial part of what makes the Glastonbury Festival what it is. The idea that this festival is taking place at a site that may have been the isle of avalon that may have been where jesus came that that um maybe where arthur is lying waiting to
当然，你还有巨蟒剧团，不过他们稍微没那么严肃。但我认为它也存在于格拉斯顿伯里音乐节中。我认为这是让格拉斯顿伯里音乐节之所以成为现在的样子的关键部分。这个音乐节在一个可能是阿瓦隆岛、可能是耶稣曾来过的地方、可能是亚瑟王躺在那里等待归来的地方举行。
come again the sense of the weird and the strange and the mysterious absolutely kind of infuses the sense of magic that um it's not going to come during the glastonbury festival as he may not come during like some you know rob during some Robbie Williams appearance or something. It would be amazing, wouldn't it? Headlining. It would be so disappointing for him. I mean, he'd emerge and Britain would not be as he had expected. Put it that way. And yet, Glastonbury, of all these sites,
那种诡异、奇异和神秘感，绝对给格拉斯顿伯里音乐节注入了一种魔力。这种感觉在格拉斯顿伯里音乐节上是不会出现的，就像罗比·威廉姆斯（Robbie Williams）登台时可能也不会有一样。那一定很棒，不是吗？作为压轴嘉宾。对他来说一定会很失望。我的意思是，他出场时，英国可能会和他预期的完全不一样。这么说吧。然而，在所有这些地方中，格拉斯顿伯里...
so Tentagel and Winchester and all these other places that have been associated with Arthur, they're basically kind of dead. I mean, there, you know, there's no, the sense of romance has gone.
所以廷塔杰尔、温彻斯特以及所有其他与亚瑟王有关的地方，基本上都有些沉寂了。我的意思是，那种浪漫的感觉已经消失了。
You go there as tourists, but Glastonbury, I think the, the vivid sense of magic is there in a way that a pilgrim going there in the middle ages might have experienced as well. I think it's a kind of very unique, distinctive place. I think the key cleavage in this podcast, actually, Tom, is that when push comes to shove,
你作为游客去那里，但我认为格拉斯顿伯里那种生动的魔力依然存在，就像中世纪去那里的朝圣者可能体验到的一样。我认为这是一个非常独特、与众不同的地方。汤姆，我觉得这个播客真正的分歧在于，当紧要关头...
you'd rather go to Glastonbury, to the festival, than to the tea room at Tintagel. And I'd rather go to the tea room at Tintagel. Possibly. Possibly. That's what makes the podcast work. I justify going to Glastonbury by saying that it was you know a historiographical exercise and tapping the sources of english myth you'd probably well you could claim for it then as a tax tax deductible expense um well so let's talk
你宁愿去格拉斯顿伯里参加音乐节，也不愿去廷塔杰尔的茶室。而我宁愿去廷塔杰尔的茶室。有可能。有可能。这就是这个播客的精妙之处。我为自己去格拉斯顿伯里辩解，说这是一次历史编纂学的练习，去挖掘英国神话的源头。你大概也可以把它当作可税前扣除的费用。好吧，那么我们来谈谈...
about we've talked about films i think we should talk about books um do you have a favorite historical retelling of the Arthurian story? T.H. White. T.H. White. You know, all that stuff about the animals, when he starts changing into fish and things. A bit weird. I love it. I love it.
我们已经谈过电影了，我想我们应该谈谈书。你有没有最喜欢关于亚瑟王传说的历史重述小说？T·H·怀特（T.H. White）。T·H·怀特。你知道，所有关于动物的那些描写，当他开始变成鱼之类的东西时。有点诡异。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
And I love all of them. And I love the weird one about the Book of Merlin. Yeah, that's too strange. Which never got published, and which he wrote against a backdrop. I think he wrote it in 1940. Yeah, absolutely. He'd become a pacifist, I think, hadn't he? He'd he wrote it in 1940. Yeah, absolutely. He'd become a pacifist, I think, hadn't he?
我所有这些都很喜欢。而且我喜欢那本关于《梅林之书》的怪书。是的，那太奇怪了。那本书从未出版，是他创作于特定背景下的作品。我想他是在1940年写的。对，绝对是的。我想他当时已经变成了一个和平主义者，对吧？
He'd become a pacifist. Yeah. Yeah. He saw the great theme of the Arthurian myth and therefore of the stories that he was telling as being how to avoid war. And I think that it just kind of heightens the power of it. But you're not a fan.
他变成了一个和平主义者。是的。是的。他认为亚瑟王神话的核心主题，也就是他所讲述的故事的核心，是如何避免战争。我觉得这进一步增强了它的力量。但你不是他的粉丝。
I find all that very strange, actually. I think T.H. White was a very strange man anyway um incredibly egotistical man and um yeah i the stuff with the wart at the beginning when he's the boy i mean that's the stuff that became the cartoon um that everybody remembers but the latest stuff i just find a little bit self-indulgent this the version of arthur i mean there's a brilliant version by rosemary supliff called sword at sunset i think yes which we mentioned on the yeah which I think is really, really good. But the... Somebody asked me to mention historical novels,
其实我觉这一切都很奇怪。我觉得T·H·怀特本身就是个很奇怪的人，一个极度自负的人。嗯，开头他还是个小男孩时变成刺猬（Wart）的那部分——我的意思是，那成了大家都记住的动画片。但后面的部分，我只是觉得有点自我陶醉。亚瑟王的这个版本——罗丝玛丽·萨特克利夫（Rosemary Sutcliff）写过一个非常精彩的版本叫《日落之剑》（Sword at Sunset），我认为是的，我们在节目里提过，我觉得真的非常非常棒。但是……有人让我提提历史小说，
and he says these are his best books, and I completely agree with him. Bernard Cornwell, who some listeners may say, oh, well, he's just sort of mass market. You find his books in W.O. Smith's. But his trilogy, I think, about King Arthur is by far the best thing he's ever written. Have you read that? I haven't, no.
他说这些是他最好的书，我完全同意他的看法。伯纳德·康沃尔（Bernard Cornwell），有些听众可能会说，哦，他只是那种迎合大众市场的作家，你在W·H·史密斯书店（W.H. Smith）到处都能看到他的书。但我觉得他关于亚瑟王的的三部曲是他写过的最好的作品。你读过吗？我没读过，没有。
It's good. If you ever read... It's sort of... What he does is he brings out the Welshness of it, as writers often do these days, and he sort of has all the magic but in such a way that the people, the characters believe in the magic but you can kind of see through it
这书很好。如果你读过的话……它有点……他所做的是展现出其中的威尔士特色，就像现在的作家经常做的那样。他保留了所有的魔法，但方式是让人们、让角色相信魔法，但你又能看穿它，
so you can see it as coincidence or as tricks or whatever. And he does it very very the atmosphere is very well conveyed anyway let's talk about politics let's talk about politics donny can i just follow up um yeah on the kind of the cultural influence because actually one thinking about the podcast we did about fascism yes the the story of of you know medieval figures with swords coming back and grails and all that kind of stuff. So the grail myth feeds into Wagner's operas. Of course, Parsifal, yeah. And thinking about T.H. White writing about Arthur in 1940. Yeah. In a way, it's the dog that doesn't bark in the night. The fact that actually Arthur is not, as far as I know, appropriated by fascists. Or if it is done, I mean, I expect there
所以你可以把它看作是巧合、把戏或是别的什么。而且他把氛围烘托得非常好。无论如何，我们来谈谈政治吧，我们来谈谈政治。唐尼，我能接着刚才的话题继续说吗？关于文化影响力，因为实际上，考虑到我们做过的关于法西斯的播客，中世纪挥舞宝剑的人物、圣杯以及所有这些卷土重来的故事。所以圣杯神话融入了瓦格纳的歌剧。当然，还有《帕西法尔》。而且考虑到T·H·怀特在1940年写作亚瑟王。是的。从某种意义上说，这就像夜里没有叫的狗。事实上，据我所知，亚瑟王并没有被法西斯分子所利用。或者如果有的话——我预计会有过这种努力，
were efforts. I don't know enough about it, but I think there probably were efforts, but they were so small scale. And maybe Arthur had become too deeply rooted. Do you think maybe so that he could resist sort of Wagnerization? I mean, you're right that there's sort of, we talked when we did about, when we did our fascism podcast, we talked about how fascism drew on modernism and sort of, but it also obviously drew on this sort of near medievalism, didn't it? So there were lots of knights and maidens. So Himmler's very into all this.
我对这方面了解不多，但我想可能确实有过这种努力，只是规模太小了。也许亚瑟王已经根深蒂固了？你觉得是不是因为这样，他才能抵制某种“瓦格纳化”？我的意思是，你说得对，我们在做关于法西斯的播客时讨论过，法西斯主义如何借鉴了现代主义，但很显然它也借鉴了这种类中世纪主义，对吧？所以有大量的骑士和少女。因此希姆莱非常痴迷于这一切。
But as far as I know, the British fascists didn't kind of call themselves the sons of arthur or something no maybe they'd be more successful dress up in armor rather than black shirts yes if there are any potential fascist dictators listening this is your you know we've given you your brand um no i don't know i wonder whether fascism sorry i wonder whether king arthur had then been was too victorian um yes whether had then been, was too Victorian. Yes. Whether he was too identified with kind of William Morris-y people with beards.
但据我所知，英国的法西斯分子并没有自称为“亚瑟王的儿子们”之类的。没有，也许他们穿盔甲会比穿黑衬衫更成功。是的，如果有任何潜在的法西斯独裁者在收听节目，这就是你们的品牌定位。不，我不知道，我在想法西斯主义——抱歉，我在想亚瑟王当时是否太维多利亚风格了？是的，他是否太维多利亚风格了？是的。他是否与留着胡子的威廉·莫里斯（William Morris）式的人物联系得太紧密了？
Yeah, yeah. You know, Burne-Jones and stuff. So it wasn't really, yeah, so it wasn't really appropriate for kind of forward-looking, aggressive. There's nothing aggressive about the Arthurian legend, is there? I mean, they don't actually do that much fighting in this sort of canonical victorian there's a lot of swooning and sort of looking out of windows and you know combing their very long hair there's not a lot of people from a night yeah exactly actually what's what one of the most powerful moments in uh the mort d'artha is when the last battle where mordred and arthur slaughter each other and all their men and they're all dead and all the knights are at the round table.
对，对。你知道，伯恩-琼斯（Burne-Jones）的作品等等。所以它真的不太适合那种向前看、具有进取心的风格。亚瑟王的传说里没有什么具有进取心的东西，对吧？我的意思是，在那种规范的维多利亚时期传说中，他们实际上并没有进行那么多战斗。有很多昏厥、凭窗远眺以及梳理他们长发的场景，并没有很多骑士厮杀的场面。对，确实。事实上，《亚瑟王之死》中最震撼的时刻之一，就是莫德雷德和亚瑟王互相残杀、他们的部下全军覆没、所有骑士都死去的最后那场战役。
And then almost for the first time, peasants appear in the narrative. And Mallory describes them creeping onto the battlefield and stripping them of their armour. And that's the only point that ordinary people appear in the story at all, I assume. Yeah, pretty much. It's interesting, isn't it? Because there are no, now that you mention it, there's no sense of the public in the Arthurian. They're just sort of yokels, cheering. And I think that's why, by and large,
然后，几乎是破天荒第一次，农民出现在了叙事中。马洛里描述他们蹑手蹑脚地潜入战场，剥下死者的盔甲。我想，这是普通人唯一一次出现在这个故事里。是的，差不多是这样。这很有意思，不是吗？因为经你这么一提，亚瑟王的故事里根本没有公众的概念。他们只是一群欢呼雀跃的乡巴佬。我想这就是为什么大体上，
I mean, a lot of historical fictionalisations of this tend to go back to the Dark Ages. That's what they, you know, it's Arthur as a warlord or Roman or whatever because then you can situate it back in the mud and the dirt yes and everything so tom i think we've um we haven't well we haven't exhausted arthur but we've probably exhausted our listeners patience um which is more important let's end with simon george's question simon george says basically does it matter if he was a real person he quotes quotes the man who shot Liberty Valance. This is the West, sir, when fact and legend collide, print the legend. So is the whole
我的意思是，许多关于这个题材的历史虚构作品往往会追溯到黑暗时代。这就是他们所做的，你知道的，把亚瑟塑造为一个军阀、罗马人或别的什么，因为这样你就可以把他重新置于泥潭和污垢之中。是的，诸如此类。所以，汤姆，我想我们并没有——我们虽然没有把亚瑟王的故事讲完，但我们可能已经耗尽了听众的耐心，这更重要。让我们以西蒙·乔治（Simon George）的问题来结束吧。西蒙·乔治基本上是说：他是不是一个真人，这重要吗？他引用了《双虎屠龙记》（The Man Who Shot Liberty Valance）里的台词：“这是西部，先生，当事实与传奇冲突时，选择刊登传奇。”所以，整场关于历史真相的讨论，其实都无关紧要吗？
conversation about the historical truth irrelevant, really? And is the myth the thing that matters? I think the question of whether he's real or not is part of the fascination. So in that sense, I mean, there's no way we can ever prove it. I think you've got to be agnostic about it ultimately I personally don't think he existed but I can't prove he didn't exist and I think that that is that's absolutely a part of the fascination of it the sense that you can situate
而神话才是唯一重要的事情？我认为他是否是真人这个问题本身就是其魅力的一部分。从这个意义上说，我们永远无法证明这一点。我认为最终你必须对此保持不可知论。我个人认为他并不存在，但我无法证明他没有存在过，而且我认为这绝对是它迷人的一部分，那种你可以将这个非凡的故事置于某个历史时刻的感觉，
this extraordinary narrative perhaps at a historical moment but I think the fact that we don't know whether it's true or not is a pretty fundamental part of its appeal. What do you think? No, I think that's obviously,
但我认为我们不知道它是真是假，这正是它吸引力极其核心的部分。你觉得呢？不，我想这很明显，
the mystery of it is absolutely the core of it. I think, I mean, one of the things we talked about when we did our Stephen Fry Troy podcast, we talked about whether the legend of Troy would die. And actually, Arthur is one story that I don't think will ever die, or at least not in the foreseeable future. And it does live on in all the, I mean, you can see it in The Lord of the Rings,
它的神秘感绝对是核心所在。我认为，我们在制作关于斯蒂芬·弗fry（Stephen Fry）特洛伊木马播客时讨论过的一个问题是，特洛伊的传说是否会消亡。事实上，亚瑟王是这样一个故事，我认为它永远不会消亡，至少在可预见的未来不会。它确实活在所有的作品中——我的意思是，你可以在《指环王》中看到它，
you can see it in Star Wars and all these sort of great pop culture leviathans. And I think the afterlife, who cares about whether Arthur is real or not, because his afterlife is actually more interesting and arguably more important. Anyway. He comes again. He does indeed. Well, he keeps coming. That's all we've got time for today.
你可以在《星球大战》和所有这些伟大的流行文化巨兽中看到它。我认为它的后续影响——谁在乎亚瑟王是真是假呢，因为他的后世影响实际上更有趣，可以说是更重要的。无论如何。他又回来了。他确实回来了。好吧，他不断归来。这就是我们今天所有的节目时间了。
It's a subject that clearly fascinates a lot of you. So please do get in touch with us on Twitter if you've got any observations about what you've heard. We'll be back on Thursday because we've got two podcasts a week now and we've got another episode of The Rest Is History when the great Michael Wood will be with us talking all things China.
这个话题显然吸引了你们中的许多人。所以，如果你对所听到的内容有什么看法，请务必在推特（Twitter）上与我们联系。我们将在星期四回归，因为我们现在每周有两个播客，而且我们还有另一期《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History），伟大的迈克尔·伍德（Michael Wood）将做客我们的节目，畅谈关于中国的一切。
Bye for now. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。